hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
perhaps one of the most famous and
popular ideas that comes up in Marcus
aurelius's meditations first emerges in
book four and then gets talked about
later in book eight and the imagery is a
little bit different uh between these
two different sets of passages in book
four it's framed in terms of getting
away from it all going off to another
place and that's actually going to turn
out to be going inside for somebody like
Marcus Aurelius as a better solution and
then in book eight there's that famous
idea of the inner Citadel or Acropolis
more literally a fortified place that
you can Retreat into so we're going to
focus here on the book for discussion
which you could say is more about like
vacation or Lee seizure getting away
from it all and Marcus starts out by
saying and he's talking to himself but
he could be talking to us
people try to get away from it all
literally they try to get to Retreats uh
on a horasis and so this uh racist part
has to do with with moving across a
distance of of space right so they try
to find places for themselves like in in
our contemporary time we say well I go
to my happy place right meaning like I
go to the coffee shop or the library or
hang out in my own apartment or I go to
this other spot that I really like where
there's natural beauty and you know
people do this as well with spending
lots and lots of money to get away to
distant lands and sit on you know he
talks about the beach sit on the beach
sipping drinks you know basking Sun that
sort of stuff and you know the ones that
that Marcus is going to talk about here
are ones that we're still doing in the
the present to the country to the beach
to the mountains right and we could
multiply this in so many ways and we
could also even talk about people doing
this with virtual spaces you know I go
to watch my favorite show you know or I
spend time online on this particular
platform in this group hanging out with
my buddies or colleagues or people who
are similarly interested in something
with me and he says this is this is what
people do right and then he says you
know
you want to do that as well but it's so
simple there's something you can do
that's much easier than that and it
doesn't cost you a dime right you don't
have to engage in some physical
relocation he says you can go inside
right ace
right so you can distance yourself from
the World by going inside what into your
very own soul your you have a Inner
Space that you can withdraw into and you
know then you're going to feel quite a
bit better so he says
um it's kind of idiotic and the word
there is that's being translated that
way is
idiotatos right and it doesn't
necessarily mean idiotic it just means
somebody who doesn't understand the rest
of the universe or under understand
philosophy so don't be like that Marcus
is telling himself go inside
now there's going to be some work that's
required and we'll get to that in a bit
but he's sort of spelling it out for
himself making it sound attractive
deliberately so right and none of this
is meant to be untruthful It's Not Mere
rhetoric but uh it's it's supposed to
make a case for doing that it says
nowhere you can go is more peaceful
Jesus right so hey sukia is peace it's
being
not in Conflict so you you don't have to
be in conflict with yourself and going
inside you don't have to be in conflict
with others or uh here's a translation
of it free of interruptions I actually
kind of think not busy is a good way to
think of it
so pragma is like something that we
occupy ourselves with a a job a task a
uh occupation and so inside if you've
got your inner Retreat set up well
you don't have to do any of that crap
right you don't have to be preoccupied
with all of the day-to-day Affairs that
are bothering you then he goes on and he
says
you know especially if you have other
things to rely on we're going to talk
about those things an instant
recollection and there it is
complete Tranquility
now notice that it's not like apothea or
some of the other things that often get
translated as Tranquility uh this is
like you know more of a enjoyment right
relaxation
so you've got tranquility and he says
and what is tranquility after all except
a certain kind of and translation of
that Harmony
um everything being in order you cosmia
and this comes from the word Cosmos
which can mean the world right so you've
got like a world within but it also
means order arrangement and not just any
sort of order but like a good order it
could mean Beauty as well so the beauty
within yourself of how things are
arranged now obviously if your inner
self is turmoil and a hot mess
Ah that's not an option for you right so
that that could be something to
worry about
um he also tells us a little bit later
after he goes through some of the stoic
doctrines that you want to think about
he says you know keep this refuge in
mind uh this
once again we see this this word meaning
some sort of distancing going on a
movement in space but now it's racist
right a place that we can go to and be
by ourselves keep it in mind remind
yourself of it remember it right so
keep this as a in mind as a possibility
for yourself and you're going to be less
bothered by things he also has something
else that's really quite interesting
here so are you supposed to go in there
and then only pop out when you have to
no this is like a brief thing to do so
he says
keep getting away from it all like that
renew yourself but
keep it brief and basic is how it's
translated here and not bad which
literally means the shallow area so you
walk into the ocean don't go you know
way out in the middle of nowhere start
swimming just you know walk in there and
then walk back out right so brief could
work for that and basic now this is very
interesting
right so the story here are the elements
the things that other stuff more
complicated stuff is made of so basic
here means like stick to the real simple
matters don't try to over complicate
this you don't need to be doing like you
know Retreat within and do all sorts of
visualization and meditation and stuff
like that no just chill out chill out
for a bit and then like he says get back
to your work get back to the rest of the
world you take a little
short
men you know tripping to yourself and
then come back out of it so you can do
the stuff that you you need to do and
you're going to be ready for it you're
going to be refreshed you're going to be
up to the tasks now how do you actually
do this it's perhaps easier said than
done one of the things that you see
coming up over and over again in the
advice that he's giving himself here is
avoid complaining right uh Deuce
so literally to be you know the kind of
person who's making things worse by what
it is that they're telling themselves
what it is that they're telling other
people so you know he says what's there
to complain about people's misbehavior
are you complaining about the thing the
world assigns you is it your body is it
your reputation you know you don't need
to complain about all of these things
you can Retreat within where these
things aren't going to to impinge upon
you right
and then we have to keep in mind a
number of stoic doctrines and he gives
you you know some of the ones that would
you know he thinks are helpful for him
you know if you're going to complain
about people's misbehavior he says well
then think about this first rational
beings exist for one another common
theme in Marcus doing what's right
sometimes requires patience right you
can't get angry at people if you want to
do the right thing no one does the wrong
thing deliberately another very common
stoic sentiment for Marcus and for other
authors the number of people who have
feuded and envied and hated and fought
and died and have been buried the fact
that you know the all the stuff that we
get very worked up about in the long run
it kind of doesn't matter right
um and then he says and keep your mouth
shut don't don't keep complaining about
stuff he says or are you complaining
about the things the world assigns you
another common Marcus thing with two
options Providence the world is arranged
in some good way that I can follow or
atoms in which case it's all random but
I can still do the right thing and he
says or is it your body right now this
is very interesting and here we come
back to the inner Retreat keep in mind
that when the Mind detaches itself and
realizes its own nature it no longer has
anything to do with ordinary life the
rough and the smooth either one remember
all that you've been taught and accepted
about pain and pleasure you can go
inside your mind and then you know
finally is it your reputation that's
bothering you ah don't worry about that
pretty soon you're going to be dead look
at the oh you know we don't remember
anything about other people the people
who do praise us how capricious they are
how are arbitrary we're in such a tiny
little point in space so keeping these
things in mind would enable you to go
Within and to not be disturbed with it
if you're bringing all sorts of clutter
into your soul
it's not going to be much of a retreat
is it
um he he mentions two other things as
well
um he said you know where he's saying
keep this refuge in mind be
straightforward look at things like a
human being like a citizen like a mortal
and among the things you turn to these
two
things have no hold on the soul right so
they don't grip it quite literally so
that means you can go within provided
you don't bring all sorts of things into
the soul he says disturbance comes only
from uh without to go within from and
here's a translation that we're gonna
have to like look at in a second from
our own perceptions not the best way of
talking about this but we'll get to that
in a moment the second thing everything
you see will soon alter and cease to
exist think about how many changes
you've seen and then he concludes by
saying the world is nothing but change
our life is only perception now
perception there which sometimes also
gets translated in other editions as
opinion not really the right term
because what he's referencing there is
Hoople this is resulted by the way in
all sorts of you know semi-fake quotes
floating or around because people don't
actually look at what Marcus is saying
in his original Greek so it's better to
say that life is assumptions or that
what what hurts us within is really our
assumptions our Hoople they saw how we
grab things uh you could say well you
know how we're we're holding on to stuff
so if we can avoid
foolish off-based assumptions about
things or judgments about things is
another way of thinking about it then we
can prepare this inner Retreat that we
can go into really anytime that we want
to and you know he doesn't say this here
but you could assume that he also thinks
that the more you do it the better you
get at it you know it's something that
you can practice over and over and over
again maybe don't start practicing it in
a very tough conflicted situation with
alarm Bells going off maybe you know try
it in more calm circumstances and then
learn how to withdraw into this part of
yourself that is you that can detach
from all these other things that
otherwise would get you upset and then
you can come out of it and go do your
duties your tasks your preoccupation all
the things that matter to you out there
in the world